computers may have just moved themselves
a little bit closer to being human in
the first round of the chest comm
computer Chess Championship LC Oh more
commonly known to the global chess
community as Leela faced off against
chess engine cheer on and this is what
happened in that game in our chess
community spotlight we started out with
e45 and after a couple of very
well-known moves we get a Rui Lopez
where Spanish game so apparently as our
understanding of chess is evolving those
playing the best chess in the universe
still prefer an opening we've been
playing for a long time too and maybe
that's comforting but after the move
1984 it was clear that Sheeran wanted to
test LCOS knowledge of a sideline
opening maybe trying to take it out of
its self-taught opening theory at this
point Leela having played millions of
games this self-taught mechanism were
the neural nylons I don't even know are
teaching LC Oh exactly what to do
perhaps there are a few holes maybe
that's what Sheeran's thinking to test
in a sideline but after Knight takes d4
and castles we saw that Leo was not to
be surprised this is of course the most
clear and theoretically well known way
for white to play and after Bishop to c5
we see Li define the most principled
move Bishop back to c4 now once the
Spanish development of the bishop is no
longer serving a purpose and that you're
not putting pressure on the knight which
of course indirectly increases your
pressure on the e5 pawn if you're white
again in a more traditional Spanish this
move makes the most sense
you bring the bishop back from a now
useless Square to a diagonal that is the
most effective one especially when
White's natural plan of d3 followed by
expanding on the Kings side is coming
now whenever your opponent has a very
easy time gaining space on one
particular side of the board
meaning the structure is is just making
making the advancement over there easy
easy PC there are two ways you can you
can challenge that one is aggressive
counter play on the other side of the
board so your opponent has a space
advantage and perhaps a little bit of a
leg up on the race on one side you
attack on the other the other way is to
try to change the pawn structure we're
gonna see that cheer on maybe not
thinking exactly in the human intuitive
terms I just described but thinking in
his own way tried to do exactly those
things against Leela in this game
he starts out with the move a5
aggressively looking for counter play on
the other side of the board if Lila
wasn't prepared to deal with this there
may even be tricks like C 6 B 5 and then
a 4 trapping the LightSquared priest
right but of course Lila is aware that
this might be coming and she puts the
kibosh on that with a 4 to highlight
real quick I did I did some analysis
actually did a lot of analysis you can
check it out at my blog which I'll
feature for you here at the end of this
video the main line theory is not a 5
the best human players in this position
have normally played 97 trying to
develop rapidly on the kingside so that
black might be best prepared to meet the
attack but one more recent game shows a
little bit of what white can get in
these types of positions after Queen h5
record Roca and then Bishop to g5 you
see immediate pressure coming to the
King side and already black kind of
afraid of what might be more to come
right in this game between Hari Krishna
and a Don Bakr we saw that Hardy
achieved a a very very strong initiative
after doubling sorry bringing the
battery to the h4d a diagonal and then
eventually expanding naturally on the
Kings side moves like h4 followed and
here we see a natural wave for whites
attack to develop when you have such a
big space advantage and such a solid
structure
now highlighting this game is not just
for those who want to be Knight d4
sideline Marie Lopez experts but after
the move in the game that Lea the played
a 4 we see why she Ron played this move
h6 to prevent the Bishop from coming to
g5 with his intention being of course to
develop this Knight to either East 7 or
f6 this move makes a lot of sense when
we consider how Hari Krishna may have
crushed his opponent down Booker with
the Bishop g5 development so that that
analysis and research there that I did
hopefully help you understand why why
Iran may be wasted a couple moves and so
we're not confused by that after the
move Knight d2 Knight f6 we see there is
no Bishop g5 but Leela is still
intending aggressive things the move f4
comes and when I first saw this I was a
little bit taken aback thinking okay is
that is that really something that a
human would be willing to laugh in the
face of danger about or is that just
Lila thinking you know this isn't that
big of a deal with the knight come to
the dark squares after a calculation
showed us that lco was indeed
Rek to accelerate the attack since I
move like 94 could be met by night to be
free where moves like 93 would actually
allow Bishop takes takes trade on c5 and
then queen h5 with a whole lot of double
attacks followed probably by a move like
rook to e1 but if the bishop retreats
itself instead of hopping into e3 now on
h3 we see that white has plenty of time
to get a big center we don't need the
Knight takes e5 excuse me and and double
attack tricks to show that white is just
much much better here and that this III
pawn
well his days are numbered so the the
idea here is to is to note as we're
trying to tell the story of a game you
know we want to appreciate genius when
we see it but learn something along the
way and we're trying to see that what is
black trying to do in order to try to
prevent White's pawn storm and pressure
on the King stuff from getting out of
control
first you go for a counter play we're
wondering were there some tactical ideas
to punish Lila's aggressive expansion
and the answer is no so black continues
to play logical moves but after h3
preventing Knight g4 now and Bishop to
e6 we see leave us first I would call a
human understanding of what to do in
these positions this is not the type of
attack that Hari Krishna got with the
bishop on g5 and the Queen on h5 where
all the pieces were already on the Kings
side this is one that's gonna take a
little more time to marinate and excuse
me that's that was a mouse let and
whenever you're trying to attack on a
side of the board and you don't have all
your pieces there right away you really
want to be careful not to change the
structure or or clarify your opponent's
defense for that reason lela plays the
very nice move Bishop back to b3 this is
the move that maintains the tension
right and it also prevents black from
doing the other thing I said that you
would want to do when you're you're
losing the pawn race moves like d5 are
just not options in these positions
because of things like 'if I've and f5
and and the pawn storm is just rolling
so what did we say black wants to do in
order to try to stop or what would you
what was the advice that anyone would
want to do in order to get counter play
or stop your opponent from having a very
easy pawn storm expansion either get
aggressive counter play yourself and win
the race like a Kings Indian type of
game you might think of or a Yugoslav
attack or try to change the game change
the race don't keep run
you're destined to lose right so try to
change the pawn structure with things
like d5 but again that's not something
that LEED allows Bishop to b3 very
patient after c6 we see the queen
building up to e1 still d5 is not gonna
be possible due to e5 and f5 so cheer on
he he blinks first in this game of
chicken and after Knight takes b3 Bishop
to b6 we see the the the next move that
shows leave those intentions to forever
prevent black from changing the
structure so that she will forever be in
peace and and build a per attack slowly
on the King side Queen to f2 very
accurate move rather than being
aggressive with Queen g3 or Queen h4
even f5 right away all decent moves to
continue the attack she plays queen
enough to simply to threaten to win a
pawn well maybe she's a little
materialistic but the point is if it
forces black to play c5 now you're even
less likely to ever see black and be
able to change the structure on that
note the moment that she forces more
pawns on the dark squares immediately
maneuvers begin to hold down the light
squares and in fact here we see a very I
would call almost a magnus carlsen
maneuver not being settled on any on any
square for the piece right really making
sure that she gets this Knight to the
ideal square she wanted to begin with
which was on b5 and eventually closes up
all counter played the Brooke comes to
c6 to try to play c4 and she she shakes
her to Kevin matumbo finger not in my
house right so what do we have now after
after the move be free we know that
black is clearly worse there's there's a
lack of counter play
there's sorry about that keeps moving
very quickly there's a lack of counter
play there's a clear space advantage for
white so the third thing you would try
to do and these are tips even though
we're looking at it from hurons
perspective where nobody's really happy
because you can already tell by the
storyline of this game who's probably
going to be end up on top but counter
playing seems to have failed the ability
to change the structure seems to have
failed now what you can do when you have
less space or you may be losing in the
races try to trade pieces one if it's a
king side race and the Queen's come off
the board less likely you'll get
checkmated but the other reason you
would try to trade pieces that with less
space that gives you more squares to
maneuver on whereas right now it looks
like everybody's wrestling their cousin
for the last piece of pie right so
black tries to play Queen h4 but again
Leela she understands what she's doing
here she plays Queen of three high level
chess understanding even if you don't
see the win of the attack you have to
know what type of pieces will help you
in that attack and make sure that those
stay on the board even if you don't see
the concrete plan yet so after Queen e3
sorry Queen of three we saw Queen e7
highlighted it should be pretty obvious
now who's who's in the driver's seat if
it hasn't been already we see some
maneuverings I wouldn't call it full
computer tickle where they're just sort
of shuffling but it was a little bit of
poking and prodding by Leela here to try
to make sure that she got the pieces
right where she wanted to be before
ultimately playing kind of the obvious
follow-through the kind of thing you can
really only do when you have a really
big space advantage with your opponent
unable to change the structure or open
the center and that's just gain more
space g4 right why not g4x glam for
those who follow me at my twitch.tv
slash Daniel red channel then you know
the inside joke of the g4 emote so g4
now
jokes aside this is this is just clearly
such a dominant position and at this
point it's really hard to see how this
game lasted as long as it did I'm not
gonna say the move number yet that's a
little Tarantino for you but we're still
gonna learn a lot about how Leela
convert on this position and to be frank
even some interesting things I noted in
analyzing this game deeply for a while
with comodo where made me leave that
didn't didn't play the absolute best
moves after the move Queen age 793 was
played the relocation of the night to a
square that more effectively attacks
blacks to weak pawns makes sense Queen
to g6 rook to g2 Queen h7 Knight to c4
and now we see the move Knight to b6 now
the one thing I didn't highlight and it
is not to poke poke it at Leela but
instead of this maneuver that ultimately
leads to a very safe approach probably
for those more aggressive at heart you
might want to take a look at what Komodo
thinks about the position after queen h7
if given a lot of time to think
Komodo doesn't think that white needed
to rima new ver the move e5 immediately
takes advantage of something really kind
of awkward and black setup only because
the Queen's on h7
that's that after D take c5 Queen d5
even moves like Knight f6 fail to rook
takes e5 and suddenly we remember that
checkmate is still greater than the
Queen even in this day and age so with
with that not being possible moves like
rook takes e5 it can be met by Queen
takes e5 and you can really see just how
dysfunctional blacks setup is with the
Queen on h7 all kinds of back rank and
efile problems and Komodos perspective
is that this was the more accurate
aggressive way to win note that I agree
with the mote especially because moves
like Queen g6 just trying to wiggle your
way out don't even work after things
like f5 the Queen has no choice but to
go right back and you might even see a
queen sack on e8 to end this game in
nice fashion so for whatever reason that
is I have a theory I'm gonna propose
later
lela seems a little bit hesitant at
times to part with material for
compensation that said those lines seem
to be pretty straight forward so perhaps
she just has a different evaluation in
her self-taught approach to the game and
that really likes to keep the structure
as is until absolutely necessary to
change it and that might explain or
justify why she took this maneuver and
justify why the next thing we're gonna
ask is why didn't Leela play Knight
takes a5 the analysis III did shows
again that after Knight takes a5 and
still following up with E 5 using the
pin white should be clearly better you
can check this out on your own time with
the latest version of stockfish or
promote or whatever you want but the the
pin on the e pawn and the big center
ensuing for white should have been
clearly enough for Lee to be better as
well but even though she took on b6
again to remind you what we just saw
took on b6 and set up winning the a pawn
after seeing the next few moves it's
hard to argue that one approach is
necessarily better than the other
because after h4 rook c7 g5 h 5 and f5
tell me you're not getting a little bit
excited keep it PG even if you're all
alone in your office but you know what
I'm saying
this is just this is just amazing for
white right I mean you really can't
argue with the pressure or that black is
so cramped not to mention you have a
Frankenstein pony over here on b6 with
the bishop that's not doing anything so
we've learned something about the
patients and the disciplined approach
white has taken with this pawn structure
from the outset but it's
instructive to note that likely there
were there was at least one moment where
a temporary pawn sack could have led to
even more pressure that's gonna come
back later in this video
after g6 Queen to h3 rook over to f6
Lila took immediately on g6 highlighted
pretty obviously by the fact that Queen
takes would just lose to rook takes f6
Komodo suggests that being a little more
patient Oh while is oh wise lizard maybe
you're right followed by similar ideas
might have been better but we're gonna
follow through with this plan because
it's not really relevant at this point
to be arguing between apples and oranges
what is relevant is that after the move
c4 we see maybe why Levi can justify the
approach he did the fact that this king
has been opened a little bit makes c4
such a dynamite move the reason for that
is it breaks the thought I have that it
might allow black to change the
structure when you're better you don't
allow that but for good reason if black
must ever take here
you're literally bringing the bishop to
the most dangerous diagonal on the board
things like Queen over to f3 and and
rook executions are probably gonna be
enough for white to win and if that's
the case meaning if black can't on
passant then you have to love c4 because
playing c4 is along the principles of
what I was saying actually and that it
completely prevents black once again
from ever changing the structure keeping
your opponent down right the patience
that white has here to make sure that
black has no positional breakthroughs
instructive stuff after Queen to g7
Bishop to f4 we see for the first time
on Queen f1 king H King g8 and then
Bishop g3 followed by Bishop h2 that
that we're gonna have a little bit of
computer computer shuffling as I like to
call it or tickle depending on what
you're into again I analyze this and
gave a little more of a detailed
thorough opinion at the blog that is
linked here in the in the notes wherever
you're watching this video but I think
that one of the things we're gonna take
away from this is that computers are
hesitant to give up a space advantageous
one of the things they value over a lot
of things right and so given the time
control and horizon affect meaning
they're not really forcing themselves to
look as deeply as they might normal
given the evaluation they're currently
holding giving themselves plus two and a
half right because they love space
they're not as as ready to consider
positional sacrifices like human beings
are and and that's something that we're
gonna see is really highlighted over the
next 30 moves what I'm hardly gonna say
anything you're welcome and just kind of
skip forward because it really shows
that even though there's a very clear
plan here for white and that is to put
the Queen on this diagonal I'll just do
it here instead of letting Leela lead
the show put the Queen on this diagonal
punch the e5 pawn through put the Queen
on e4 where g6 becomes the most obvious
target and combine that with the
pressure along the sixth rank and this
game is essentially gonna play itself
there's almost nothing that changes
about this structure from now until that
move being finally being played in about
30 moves which really highlights again
what I'm saying that it is most the time
all of us on our knees worshipping the
Nuge the new chess gods built of
artificial intelligence silicon silicon
vally chess gods but it does show that
there are some things grandmaster strong
chess players can quickly recognize
about our position that the computers
just refused to go for until they
absolutely have to right like the
contempt factor the fact that they want
to avoid the draw so let's take a look
and see exactly the the real-life
version of everything I just described
and you're gonna see that it's really a
game of tickle that doesn't really have
anything going for Leela and until she
plays I believe the move was probably
around 74 75 until she starts to to just
to get the King out of the Queen side
yeah with this move King f1 he or she
recognizes I think the plan for the
first time based on having analyzed this
and see how the computers evaluate
because because for whatever reason for
better or worse white made the decision
that when this ePHI breakthrough came
she didn't want the king anywhere over
here on the Kings side where maybe it
could be open there are certainly some
possible diagonal shots for the Queen
whatever I don't think you could really
make that big of an argument that e5 is
any better but the King were ultimately
landed over here on d2 or d1 but it is
something that that does show for the
first time at least she was no longer
continuing to shuffle right that there
was
some sort of plan in mind and ultimately
once that King arrived on d1 she did
make the breakthrough and for forgive me
for showing you all these moves but hey
you want to appreciate the real thing
just like me right start for King b1
queen g2 rookie 7 we're in pretty much
the exact same position where I
highlighted 'if I've need to be played
other than the fact that the king is
here instead of g1 and Leela finally
busts open the door with the movie 5
perhaps the fact that I said she's a
little materialistic was more than just
a jest earlier in this video
willing to part with the pawn doesn't
seem like there was any reason to wait
as long as she did again other than the
fact that I guess black wasn't going
anywhere for a while maybe she was
having a Snickers Queenie for King h7 of
course you see g6 is falling and the
next few moves really are are just
flawless execution of gobbling up a
second pawn we're gonna see the pieces
maneuver for white to get the other rook
into the 6th rank that this last use
we're not just useless shuffling a very
nice recognition that the bishop is no
longer very most useful on h2 hitting e5
but now that the c5 pawn and b6 pawns
are gone the Bishop was most useful
coming around here to e1 where the rook
and Bishop can gang up so again just
really really nice stuff there from from
leader to relocate that that forces row
k-6 and now with a couple more Tempe
moves we see black put in a sort of zerg
swung here because of the threat of
Queen to b7 she finally does surrender
the 6th rank and here comes the other
tower of power now this is where believe
it or not I think we've learned a lot
but this is where the video gets really
interesting and those of you who may
have come in because of our kind of fun
and sexy thumbnail or wonder exactly
what it means to troll somebody you're
about to find out and this is what
really had me on the edge of this my
seed and ultimately what actually
inspired me to do this video is what
we're gonna see from here after excuse
me after the move Queen to g8 we see the
road come to c6 threats on g6 4 4 to g7
this game seems momentarily overwrite
the move Queen e2 is played is brilliant
to pause your video if you want to try
to solve White's threat of a mating - I
gave you a second too late the move is
Queen takes h5 followed by rook h6 mate
right so with that threat in mind Black
has to give up the g6 pawn
King situ is really just I guess a Leela
waiting move because the next move
coming is real the unstoppable could
have been played right away we see the
transition and with it again we see
white probably in a pretty crushing
position here leave the plague queen e4
and you can check out the blog at chess
comm again on the de chinon us to see my
my thoughts about how Queen f3 was more
accurate and again it's further proof in
my theory that maybe Leila's self-taught
approach is still leaning a little bit
too much toward materialism and the
reason for that you're gonna see is if
you look at the analysis you'll see the
queen of three I think was almost in the
in the realms of announcing mate but
Queen e4 followed by Queen to c6 I I
think missed the defensive shot efore
here ex clan bye-bye cheer on which okay
gives up material which is why Lila may
not have considered it as the best
offensive resource for opponent right
not thinking that way it does open up
the e5 square and added a few more moves
before she was winning everything I just
said could be total hogwash in the sense
that maybe she knew exactly what she's
doing
and went in for this for the exact
reason that she wasn't done having her
fun or having her way did I just implied
true human emotion to a computer don't
believe me keep watching the next few
moves this game is simply over and if
you turn on Komodo stockfish or anything
else the the computer starts announcing
things like matin 30 on moves like b6 a5
these are the obvious things to do when
you're up a queen and a whole bunch of
pawns for two rooks right no reason to
change anything significant about this
structure apparently Leela disagreed
Queen f6 and the move that may have
changed the game forever
showing computers apparently like to
torture their opponents showing I am
really applying human emotion to an AI I
think I am queen take c7
what are you doing right seriously good
there was no reason to do this and again
check it out the mates are the mate the
winds are just obvious but know why I
wanted to take here and prove that these
four pawns be better than the Brooke
guess what it gets worse Leela is not
done after chess here she repeats moves
there's no reason to repeat boobs
literally this move and this move our
announcing mates in 19 take it out if
you don't believe me King b6 rookie six
she's just playing tickle but rather
than advance the a pawn she plays see
five takes the evaluation from like plus
20 or announcing mates back to like plus
10 if you go to the computer so she's
just literally having fun and this isn't
some sort of approach by her that's
different again we see we see d4 being
played unnecessarily not the most
accurate way to win in an undeniable
sense and after a few more moves we've
reached the final sort of climax if you
will where there's undeniably no way
that leave those creators or whoever
they programmed her to be self-taught
and apparently torture her food before
she eats it happens right here went
after the last series of checks she she
sacrifices her Queen again completely
unnecessary and then goes on to
sacrifice every pawn in under promotion
fashion I mean I you can see the smile
on my face I was watching this game and
like everybody else at the chest outcome
could be I was like what is she what
like this is not what computers do to
win and okay here black didn't take it
cheer on maybe after the MU King g6 was
hopeful that Leo would actually
undermine her her advantage almost
completely by getting a bishop here
right that might be a fun way to see a
computer versus computer Knight Bishop
mate but apparently she finally came to
her senses and decided to get a queen
maybe she doesn't know how to do the
knight Bishop mate and if so she should
watch my video lecture on on YouTube
about how to check me with the knight
Bishop but she didn't she instead
finishes off the job finally in the most
accurate fashion and we have maybe the
first time one chess engine has trolled
another and done so in in in fashion and
in style I guess hopefully you enjoyed
this video I appreciate you taking the
time to watch it as I said you can go to
chess comm and check out the blog you
can also go over to chess comm slash
computer chess or slash cccc where you
can view the computer Chess Championship
going 24/7 around the clock you can also
go to twitch.tv slash computer chess all
of those links are in the show notes if
you want to check out the the live the
live broadcast of these games if you
want to read my blog like I said head
over to chess comm you can also join the
official cccc fan club a lot of C's
there you know but apparently we're into
that sort of thing we'll rethink some of
that branding maybe down the road but
none of that matters what matters is we
just saw an awesome game had a lot of
fun and I appreciate you watching and
subscribing to our YouTube channel peace
out